I think we should be very concerned with
the youth unemployment crisis at the
moment because we are actually in danger
of losing a whole generation we are in
danger of losing all the young people
that actually need to drive this well
further and solve some of the crises
that we are seeing at the moment one of
the things that I'm doing here at the
World Economic Forum is to talk about
the multiple crises to say we're not
only experiencing an economic and
financial crisis we also seeing a
resource and climate crisis that is very
severe and that the crises are
interlinked which means that one of the
reasons why our economies are suffering
at the moment is actually that it's hard
to recover in a time where the trend on
commodity prices resource prices have
been reversed Mackenzie just did a study
before Christmas showing how energy how
resource prices have come down from 1900
to 2000 every year but the last ten
years they've gone up more than they
came down the previous 100 years this
means that average commodities like
steel water energy rare earth materials
silver copper all the metals that we
need for our production and consumption
are going up and becoming both rising in
a large speed but also becoming a
volatile so we are in a new situation
that's a game-changer there's really a
new paradigm shift of the basis of our
economies that the resources have risen
in this way so if we want to solve that
problem together with the economic and
financial crisis we should look at all
the new innovation that can help us
become more resource-efficient that can
help us handle the the natural resources
in a more intelligent way getting more
out of less so to speak and actually i
lo the International Labour Organization
just came out with some figures on how
many jobs new jobs can be created
worldwide if we were to
really take this problem serious and try
and solve the the resource crisis and
they point to 15 to 60 million jobs new
jobs created worldwide in just handling
the the resource crisis and trying to
get more out of less so I see this as a
big opportunity of creating some of the
new jobs so that we're not just sending
what jobs from one part of the world to
the other but actually creating new jobs
another last figure that I would like to
point to is a figure saying that we
could save around 2.9 trillion dollars a
year in 2030 if we manage resources more
in challenges it's intelligently and
save resources and really try to make
this shift towards a circular economy
where the resources are being circulated
over and over again and where we protect
our oceans our forests our air our water
all the things that are the basis of our
lives and our economy then we will have
huge savings and they would of course be
a large business opportunity connected
to this agenda so let's solve all three
crises at the same time